is Norma she's a local crime beat
reporter for a digital outlet and radio
station in Veracruz
the most violent states in Mexico
serving as a key location for criminal
groups engaged in both drug and human
trafficking
we're traveling with her as she heads
out to cover a crime scene
no I'm not scared Veracruz is also the
deadliest Mexican state for journalists
31 have been killed here in the past
decade
as elsewhere in Mexico getting threats
for simply doing the job is normal
since the government launched a
so-called war against cartels and
criminal organizations in 2006 killings
of reporters have gone up there's both
crime and Corruption have become more
and more entrenched
at least 13 journalists have been killed
in Mexico this year won the whole of
2021.
why not in May Norma got this call after
she reported on a police operation
she had to flee the town local
authorities couldn't protect her
now she's back working but in fear for
her life but in Mexico the threats come
not just from the country's rampant
gangs and wherever there is organized
crime there is collusion with local
authorities mostly on the municipal
level but also on a state level and
especially outside the major
metropolitan areas in Mexico journalists
are often part of a relatively small
community a small pool of reporters
especially those who cover what they
call the notarojan Mexico which is crime
and violence and traffic accidents who
affect the interests of very powerful
players in the country
there's a clear line dividing us as the
international press dropping in here no
International journalist has been killed
in more than a decade in Mexico and the
national and especially the local
journalists that are covering this day
in and day out they're really the ones
that are at risk we've organized crime
threatening journalists and control the
flow of news I asked Norma how it felt
wondering what she could and couldn't
report
as if you were on a glass Bridge one
full step and you fall
is
I wouldn't be here
John Holman Al Jazeera Bella Cruz